um I don't I don't even know how to
introduce this
George Santos says he survived an
assassination attempt
that is the latest Rachel Maddow has
surfaced video of an interview that
George Santos gave in Portuguese okay so
the clip we're going to look at is in
Portuguese with subtitles and I'll pause
momentarily you know brief every once in
a while to tell you what's being said
he claims he was the victim of an
attempted murder that he survived and it
led to him being under police protection
there's no evidence of this I should
mention listen to this so at the top of
the show I went through a long but
definitely not exhaustive list of the
known lies of freshman Republican
Congressman George Santos of New York uh
you're probably familiar with some of
the greatest hits by now the volleyball
star and Wall Street fortune and all
that stuff right but here's something
you have not heard before did you know
that Congressman George Santos also
claims he was the target of an
assassination attempt which required him
being put under official police
protection wow that is what George
Santos claimed last month in an
interview with a Brazilian podcast the
podcast is called radio novello a
presenta yeah give my pronunciation
radio novello a presenta they shared
this video from the interview
exclusively with us so you won't see
this anywhere else but I want you to see
it in this interview then Congressman
elect George Santos is speaking with the
hosts in Portuguese so we have subtitled
it he starts off talking about an
alleged Act of vandalism which he says
was targeted at him simply because he's
a Republican
but then in the midst of that he says oh
also someone tried to murder him
[Music]
um
so he says this happened in Florida at a
near after New Year's Eve parties
so he says the vandalism was because he
was at a Republican party
um
okay so there he casually mentions I
already suffered an assassination
attempt which I survived
yeah very very casual we had police
protection etc etc we have already
suffered an attempt on my life an
assassination attempt yeah
there was an assassination attempt
really
um then Congressman elect George Santos
did not elaborate on his claim in the
interview We Have Tonight reached out to
Congressman Santos's office
to get more information about him saying
that he was the victim of an attempted
murder yeah um getting New York police
protection at his home as a result there
ought to be a record of that sort of
thing if it happened we've inquired
about this claim from him we have not
heard back we do live in Hope Mr Santos
did offer more detail about a different
act of violence he says was committed
against him in this interview with the
same Brazilian podcast he said he was
the victim of a very very very
Brazen mugging in the middle of the day
in the middle of New Year one of one of
New York City's busiest thoroughfares
very logical
[Music]
oh my God he says oh God so first of all
he says this was at Fifth and 55th okay
I don't understand how any such mugging
could take place at 5th and 55th in the
middle of the day he volunteers before
asking me any questions they weren't
black they were even white but they
still even white people these weren't
even black folks and they still had the
audacity to Rob him in broad daylight
they took his watch yeah and his shoes
in the middle of the day on Fifth and
55th he is
yeah okay so I don't know that any of
these things are true but these are
extraordinary claims and it appears as
though the lies simply will not stop
voters are now furious with this guy he
claims I'm not hearing from anybody who
wants me to resign let's talk about that
next
there is something you use at home every
day that is significantly harming the
planet and it is your toilet paper 30
million trees are destroyed every year
for toilet paper in the U.S alone
deforestation is a contributor to
climate change and I think moving away
from tree based toilet paper is
something we can all do and that's why I
asked real paper to be our sponsor real
paper is a toilet paper made 100 from
bamboo stocks which grow forever so no
cutting down trees and all of real
papers packaging is plastic free think
of all those big plastic bags you've
thrown out over the years real paper is
a b Corp certified by the forest
Stewardship Council and real paper
plants one tree with every purchase you
make and the best part is you can do a
part to fight climate change without
making any sense sacrifice because real
paper is soft and fluffy and durable
just like traditional toilet paper
you're used to guys this is a no-brainer
for anyone who cares about the issue of
deforestation give real paper a try go
to realpaper.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman for 30 off your first order plus
free shipping the link is down below